back to the rstudio Enterprise Community
Meetup hope everyone's having a great
start to the week if you've just joined
now feel free to say hi through the chat
window and maybe where you're calling in
from because we're focusing on shiny
today maybe also share what's your
favorite shiny app you've ever created
or a public app that you've seen I
always love to see new examples
special welcome if this is your first
time joining us today this is a friendly
and open Meetup environment for teams to
share different use cases and teach
lessons learned just meet each other and
ask questions too and so they happen
every Tuesday at 12 eastern time I'll
say most Tuesdays at 12 eastern time but
I'll share a link in the chat where you
can find out about their upcoming events
too
but together we're all dedicated to
making this space inclusive and an open
environment for everybody no matter your
experience or industry or background
and during the event you can ask
questions wherever you're watching from
so if you're on YouTube you can ask
there if you're on LinkedIn you can ask
there and you can also ask questions
anonymously as well through the slido
link that I'll just put up on the screen
here right now
we'll try to answer as many questions as
possible at the end of the presentation
too
today we have the pleasure of learning
about open source environmental
monitoring done with shiny
and with that I would love to bring my
friend here up on stage Wayne Jones
who will be presenting today
thanks Wayne
thank you very much can you see the
screen everything looking okay
Yep looks good thanks a lot well thanks
a lot for the opportunity to talk to you
today about my experiences
with open source monitoring with with
shiny uh I'm going to talk principally
today about an application that we've
built called gws that that stands for
groundwater spatial temporal data
analysis tool a little bit by myself and
Wayne Jones I'm a principal data
scientist in Shell Global Solutions and
I've been working in shelf for 15 years
now and I would say that this is the
project I've been working on for the
longest almost since I've been at show
um a little bit about soil and
groundwater activities at Shell and The
Wider industry
um shell obviously operates globally
across different countries with
different types of assets here I think
there's a terminal here pictured in the
bottom right we manage a large amount of
land and we have
um
some cases of groundwater risk and
Remediation for example if Perpetual
tank at a at a fuel station leaks
we have to remediate the situation we do
that with working with the environmental
regulators and we do things proactively
monitoring so our larger sites typical
maybe refineries or terminals we always
monitor the groundwater
um we will look for any contamination
um the way that we operate in Shell is
we work with third-party environmental
engineering companies they typically go
out and they do the analysis give us
reports and they work with the
environment Regulators who can come up
with the mediated solution
and we've got a long history of research
and development with Academia and Joint
industry project
um and we always work in a kind of open
transparent manner working hand in hand
um
so first and foremost what is gws that
well generous that is a collaborative
project between shell and the University
of Glasgow it's a user-friendly open
source decision support tool for
analysis reporting of groundwater
um underlying it is effectively the our
statistical programming language and we
use a combination of what our packages
obviously including shiny uh together
with some custom developed algorithms
we've built at the University
it's been around for a long time I think
I can't remember to be honest with you
it's that long ago but I think it's
about it's around 2010 when we released
version
um there's a few links there for where
you can actually download and install to
the rest up there probably the best for
this audience today is is that do the
restapp.net and that's hosted by the
University of Glasgow
I'm not going to start by telling you
where it is now I'm going to start by
saying where it was effectively right so
the way
Jesus that used to work before shiny was
effectively it was a combination of
an Excel add-in
which contain various functions
including data input temperature and it
is an example of
a very old-fashioned looking data input
template and we'd had a graphical unit
space using the R panel package which is
basically a wrapper for DCL TK which is
you can see a snapshot of the GUI here
in the bottom right there
I don't know if any of you guys probably
not have actually used tickle VK it is
um
it has very strange programming Paradigm
very very difficult
the programming and the R panel function
package is basically a wrapper which
wraps up some of these
then I say obscure tickle ta functions
right and that makes it a bit more
convenient but the longer shot of it is
still very very hard right
um and so when shiny became popular it
was actually the University of Glasgow
that approached shell and said look we
think this was strategically a really
good idea to do this and what's more
they were willing to go above the point
Beyond and Call of Duty and do it an
active bit for themselves as well right
and in that process we took you know get
had come about as well right and it
shows how long this has been around for
uh and I've put a GitHub site there
where we host the to us that our package
there and it's open invisible to view
and you can you can view all the code
from there
before I give a demonstration of the
tool in action I think it's worth
pointing out what it's actually designed
to do
um it's there for the analysis of trend
and groundwater
how that typically works right is you
get a state and you construct Wells
within you access the underlying water
table you take samples of the water send
them to the lab for analysis and they
come back with the concentrations of the
various different solutions
[Music]
hydrocarbons and lots right
and the job of due with that is to help
analysts interpret Trends as he's going
down is it going up where does this
concentration spread into
something and to do that we use uh
smoothing statistics and give more
examples of this during the
demonstration as well
um both smoothing in one-dimensional
Time series for example using
um local linear aggression we also use
spatial smoothing I think we do the
groundwater elevation now but uniquely
in the industry we use a spatial
temporal smoother
um which effectively it's the way that
the industry typically works is you get
a concentration contour for one round of
sampling it's another concentration
Contour independently to the second
round as you collect this information
through town and so on and so on and so
on so in the old traditional way of
doing things you know you would have
three sort of spatial creaking models
here
um but you left that does it differently
effectively does it in a wanna right and
there are various different benefits of
doing that which is the subject of the
paper that I'll reference later on one
of it being data extraction efficiency
where you just get more information out
for the same amount of data if you get
one spacious Central model rather than
having separate independent spatial
um worth pointing out that it was with
the help of the University Glasgow the
underlying methodology for the space
system statistics is analyze lines
line-based methodology and we went for
this way more than anything because of
the speed of computation
there are other things like calcium
process modeling three-dimensional
cleaning
but we found
take a long time to run
so at that point there I'm going to move
over to a bit of a demonstration of what
the actual tool Congress that off by
saying what it used to look like so you
get a look and feel through uh we have a
gws that add-in and this is typically
how most people in Industry access to
University
um
here uh the way it used to work was here
there's um
this is the old data input format here
there's effectively two tables and they
need to be populated you've got the
historical
monitoring data table this is the name
of the well the constituent
um the date it was sampled together with
a concentration value and given units
there as well in addition to
concentrations you can add groundwater
elevations this is how high the water
table is and that enables you to
estimate groundwater flow Direction
um on the second table is a
table of the well coordinates and these
are treated like characters
yeah
um what happens is
um in terms of the connectivity between
uh XL and ah it's a bit of a hack even
being totally honest with you when you
when you click
um analyze from the data menu here
there's various options that I don't
have time to go into but basically
What's Happening Here is is it's using
VBA macro
it's a basically it takes to create CSV
files here and then it's running uh in
batch mode and returning this uh
graphical user interface
this is again going back to the old
style of doing things here so you can
see here we have um
quite involved there's Rachel there's
quite a lot going on there's quite a hit
to the senses
um but it does give you the different
graphical output right but then I wanted
to show you this to show you the
progression in terms of um
uh you know graph keys and space in
terms of how it looks on the eye and the
function and the underlying
functionality
uh Professor Adrian Bowman who was
behind this R panel package I asked him
how did he feel about shiny coming along
and basically taking over and he was
he was ecstatic he was really pleased
you know it just shows broke
anyway I'll move over to the newer
version of that but on this country
version version 3.12 the XL admin looks
a lot nicer there's various different
data input templates here in addition to
a basic example we have a more
comprehensive example it shows off the
more ground brought the specific
functionality but one of the nice things
about it is the ability to Overlay a
shape file as well
um probably won't have time to do that
there's a basic example if I get more
time I'll highlight that one here I just
want to show the basic functionality
here
again it's the same trick it's copying
these into csvs
using them as input files into our
running in batch mode and then it
does the modeling and then it provides a
graphical user interface
still working on it at the moment
here we go in in shiny so this is the
new shiny graphical using space for for
what you'd address that
um
again you can see instantaneously it
looks a lot nicer it looks a lot more up
to date
um you don't have to Overlay all the
graphs in one place you know there's
lots of tabs and more sophisticated
coupons now
this
initial plot here is called the spatial
plot you've got the locations of the
wells together with the names of the
wells underneath it and above it the
last constant the last measured value on
top of the well location
overlaid or superposed with the axis on
the right hand side there are the
predictions of this spaceship
and you can scroll it back
scroll It Forward in time for example
when you basically build up an image of
how this blue
math has changed over time okay
um in addition to that one of the
functionalities and
to
better quantify what exactly has
happened to the plume because
without having these objective measures
it we're getting confused about the
interpretation but let me give an
example of how we come across that we
the expressive button here boom
Diagnostics what this does here it takes
a Time slice from this spatial Temple to
the
delineates a plume with a prescribed
threshold value of the 10 micrograms per
liter once it's enclosed it uses
here numerical interface these
quantities and gives you a blue mass and
a plume area and you can effectively
track that through time so you can
effectively you know measure the total
amount of contamination at your site
and you get to press this tab here for
example what you get is a Time series
blue Mass total plumeria and the average
between concentration right so this is
an objective measure that we calculate
from the underlying analysis
um and which doesn't rely on the
interpretation of the user of these
plots
there's various drop down boxes here on
the right hand side where you can choose
different different options different
substances from the initial data sets
I've done xylene there you can change
the units there's a range of different
types if for whatever reason you just
want to plot the data you can do plot
arrange circles for example you can
toggle while labeled on and off show the
groundwater Contour here so that the
blue arrows correspond to the estimated
groundwater direction of flow and
strength effectively you can see in this
situation here
um because the water levels are high in
the kind of North West Region and low in
the Southeast we anticipate the
groundwater flow in that direction
the blue arrows are estimated with a
technique of doing a triangulation
between the Well locations and fitting a
plane to them which is reading the
gradient of that off but the Contours
are done with a low ass smoother that's
basically up to the local linear
regression the nice thing about here the
two independent methods of of trying to
estimate the same thing and you can see
generally speaking Yeah effectively
yeah which is nice there's a whole host
a variety of different ways that you can
output the format as well one of the
nice things is the ability to generate
PowerPoint animations
what this does here is it it basically
runs it through time in an animation and
it will output the results in a in a
PowerPoint slide pack like so
and they're all overlaid exactly over
one but they're right and so typically
we these styles of Contours being
attended to um
reports that go to environmental
directly
um
loads of other things I can show I'll
just go to the time series plot this is
a combination of where you can look at
different Wells and the different
substances and well by the well-level
bases it plots the data and it overlays
it with this with a with a local and new
regressions to the uh of the point again
um challenging intervention where they
just typically do you know linear fits
you know and there's examples here where
you know interpretation of a linear fit
is a lot different to what it was with
the transmitter linear fits as just it's
flat basically whereas this trans smooth
is not constrained to be monotonic in
Direction and interpretation here I
think is closer to truth which is namely
increasing rapidly
foreign
Ty again you can overlay the groundwater
levels you can show Legends you can
export in a variety of different formats
um and there's some other
functionalities which allow you to
generate specific reports as well which
is neat because this one is a two by two
Matrix effectively more of a different
combination with Wells there
um
obviously there's potentially a lot of
different combinations of wells and
solids right so what we have here is the
trend and threshold indicator Matrix
this is where it has a high is a lookup
table of all the combinations if you
think particular time slides and it
gives you a color key reporting on the
trend right and you can see
um
that you know Green that green means
it's trending downwards very quickly red
and dark red strongly increasing so this
is a high level lookup about what wells
you may be having issues with and the
ones you draw any attention to here are
Benzene from one two one seven Bond
Benzene from 1 11. let's do a deep dive
on that let's go Benzene munching or
seven and you can see yes indeed that
this byte is increasing rapidly
um and 11 time as well right and that
might be harder to spot if you're going
through each one of them individually
um there's an equivalent plot but not
looking at Trend but the absolute level
we're there is basically it's
butterflies only above below
of statistically not difficulties
um there's a variety of different
um Lots here as well this is one of my
personal favorites it uses lattice as
most might people might recognize right
uh we haven't moved into GT plots yet we
might be one day in the future
um
uh and you can just customize this this
is basically all the concentration data
for all the wells at this site right you
can see that the different volumes are
in different colors and each cell
corresponds to a different world
very very concise plot it's also quite
useful to looking at the correlation
between the difference
um in addition to that there's a spatial
temporal predictions and this is
basically where it overlays the
predictors from the state of Templar
model on top of the observed data just
the biggest measures and you can see in
this example
reasonably well the only thing I would
say is that models slightly of
predicting the concentrations that
manager are one and slightly
underpredictable to help to choose a
different value accordingly like that as
well
you can customize the color key this was
something that was implemented and this
is the color key for the spatial party
and this is something that was actually
implemented
in response to the user feedback
um
and then there's various different
options that you can go into that
the most important one being that the
model set of the resolution of the
actual underlying piece by model and its
combination of basically how long are
you willing to wait for this is the
complexity of sufficiency of the model
affected so it's a trade after two
um there is other functionality that I
can talk about but I just want to show
one more thing
in the comprehensive example I've
alluded to this earlier I'll start
running this
um again in response to user feedback
um
when we first released this
um people the first thing that people
ask for is to Overlay your basement
and in this third column here
table here we have um you can basically
point it to a shape file
and then
it will pick up all the remaining shape
files
and then it will just overlay
um that
basic Vector mapping geometry all over
the predictions of the spatial temporal
smoothie you'll see it now so there you
go look you can see that this is
actually a petrol station and these are
the individual fuel pumps this really
helps the environmental uh Consultants
you know it gives them it grounds them
in where exactly these concentrations
are
um
this is I've highlighted to you the
local version of the app
this is for local installation you know
when you install it is in our package
effectively right uh together with the
Excel add-in but there's a a publicly
available
um implementation of this online and
then this is the advantage of going
shiny right the previous architecture
that was only available locally but with
shiny you can deploy it over the web
and you know in the past it also opens
the door in terms of various different
file formats right so in the passage
which is blocked down to act Aladdin but
here we have the CSV you can manual
enter the data and you can also rely on
and then this is there's a couple of uh
examples here as well uh the link will
be in the slides afterwards don't worry
so um have a go yourself and
see uh and let me have your feedback
uh at that point I'll move back so in
the slides which will get shared
afterwards there's some screenshots of
what I've just demonstrated but I'll
move on to the
kind of
status of where we're at now with due to
the rest of that
um
it's been used and been around for for a
long long time
and when we did
the last question here there was four
main points that it came down to sort of
business benefits one is in supporting
the design optimization of monitoring
remediation programs right you know
you just see things you wouldn't
otherwise see effects of it effectively
right you know
um early identification and potentially
releasing releases
um one example here is when we were
actually
um
promoting to rest that the first version
the way we did it was we asked people
for their data sets and we presented the
data back to them and you ask that and
even in those few exercises we saw what
they noticed things that they hadn't
previously seen so it really does
you know give you more insights than the
traditional methods that they were guys
were looking at rapid interpretation of
complex data sets it's principally
designed for the smaller data sets you
know where you have typically the retail
fuel stations
where you have small data sets where
it's perhaps not worth setting up an art
for our Gis for example data set but it
works equally well for the large data
sets as well
um and it's you've got inbuilt uh
reporting functions which take you know
consultants in the passengers to take
ages to do it imagine replicating some
of this stuff in in Excel that would
take you ages and age
that on its own is a huge Time Saver
um
one of the you know the good things
about being open source is that it's
open and free to use right
um and it gets used a lot more than it
than it would be it wasn't open source
exactly
um one of the bad things about open
source is you don't know exactly where
it's being used
but you know we've collected evidence of
of its applied use and it's been used
you know typically Global globally it
turns up in all manner of different
places that that you know today just
surprises me you know it's been used on
a Navajo Indian reserve in America it
was it was discussed in a Indonesian you
know student
um geology group it's been used across
the US Australia you know Pakistan and
you know loads of different places
broken there's a variety of different
use cases at this web link here which is
which is really useful
we've worked with with many
environmental regulators and you know
referenced in some of the environment
Regulators guidance document and you
know with just highlight there the UK
environment agency but we have done
you know joint presentations with the US
EPA they particularly like the clean
diagnostic tools ability to quantify you
know the degree of contamination in the
political time affecting it and we are
you know included in the standardized or
more guidance documents for the field of
groundwater monitoring so it's well
established and it's been around for a
long time it's still being used more and
more and more I suppose the only
downside of being open source is I don't
know
where it isn't being used right so where
are the gaps affected me is something
I'd like to learn so I could perhaps
yeah you know
I suppose you know
retrospectively looking back at you know
why
why it's been successful and this was a
good exercise
I suppose I you know they haven't
written it down it was the right tool
for the right time right it was
it wasn't trying to be more than it
actually was it wasn't a hugely huge
team sophisticated
statistical tool either right you know
it's it's it's basically a visualization
tool with some with some
three-dimensional smoothing effectively
right
um
um but but critical was adopting your
presence especially in the field of
groundwater monitor environmental model
of the general life it increases
accessibility so more and more people
use it more and more people that use it
the more well-respected
and adopted it becomes
also there's transparency you know if we
were using a black box tool that right
our environmental Regulators may be
inclined
to question the underlying methodology
whether it's here all laid out with all
the code fully transplanted so it's
fully open distinct
and you know it's free to use which is
also
um important you know especially in
certain countries but the third world
countries in the world to work toward
using it now
um another critical success has been
developing that strong relationship with
an academic
wave
typically done it with engagements with
a string of different PhD students which
has helped build that relationship
working now you know over 10 years and
we're on our third PhD student as well
I think it's also worth pointing out
that
the University was incentivized uk-based
University by the research Excellence
framework right and this is about
quantifying the impact of academic work
in society effectively right and I think
this was probably
one of the reasons why Glasgow were
willing to go above beyond the Call of
Duty and put their own time and
resources into actually developing the
shiny version of geographic right so
they paid for a postdoc for six month
period
to report the code where it was before
into
um
actors include computational speed right
you know when you work in Glasgow they
say well there's kind of different
models we could do but there was always
a trade-off between the time it took to
run a model versus
um you know the correct modulator and I
think we hit upon a reasonable
compromising using piecewise they're
very very quick
I don't think it would have been adopted
in the way it had been if it took you
know sort of hours for it to run the
model I think you've got anywhere near
to where it is now the fact that it's
computationally fast
is one of the in my opinion anywhere on
the critical success but
and that might be you know
slightly against some of the statistical
Penance out there but out there right
but um I definitely think it was the
right choice
um again no special data requirements
this is interesting as well right you
know we didn't have to put any special
data that we didn't already have it's
just a case of formatting it in a
particular way for data input so there's
no barriers effectively
we made it as open and transparent and
reduce the barriers for entry made it
easy as possible
and of course the one I would like to
talk about specifically is adopting that
and I think that's been absolutely one
of the critical best factors
um and there's many benefits who are
doing that effect Ive no it's
you know first and foremost it's a more
sophisticated up-to-date graph we've all
using interface and I only know that
because of what I was using previously
right you know it it was um
you know some of the older Technologies
there now right and not as nice to
program in you know it's very difficult
and as a consequence of that it's hard
to support and really develop and
maintain it based right but you know
shiny has a Str is a structured
graphical user programming as a
graphical
as a GUI programming syntax which I
really like it makes sense there's plug
into your documentation out there
there's plenty of tutorials and there's
plenty of support out there
um it's taking GMS that as well from
being a local installation to specific
users to be more widely talked online
all the benefits of having an online web
app get me to a stall anything you can
just go to web URL and that's it
and there is a publicly available
version here
um and that's been hosted by the
University of Glasgow they've got a
subscription that's only apps to IO
however you know this is mostly the
demonstration purposes I would say or
buying if the date is you know
insensitive or but if you are concerned
about data security and then there are
two pieces of advice right one is you
can go down the local installation so
keep it local right so any data you have
doesn't move off your own PC for example
or if you want an online version of it
what you can do is is you can basically
uh build your own internal shiny server
service internally within your computer
infrastructure right and I know you know
shall we have our own art connect
internal service and no BP we've got
their own internal service because
they've done it they've got advice from
me on how to do it basically but
obviously they see the value I'm using
doomless that as well to the point where
they've actually subscribed to the
Chinese
and
uh
another benefit as well is that you know
it's been successful that you rest that
but the underlying architecture is
actually being used for other open
source tools all right so there's a
monitoring toolbox
um inspired by kukawi again it's an open
source
um monitoring tool for elmap or Elm
apple is the kind of pollution you see
on top of Puddles you know when you see
the rainbows on top of the bottle it's
more related to that type of
contamination and again open source
toolbox you can go from there the
interesting thing about this one is yes
it's usually do rest that as a modeling
template
but in this one here and this is of
bringing on to our studio and what the
latest things out with our studio is
using the combinations you both are and
piping code in the same place
and I asked them you know why why why
why why did you do it in both languages
right because I think it was easy to
maintain in one language so they said
you know
it was resources right they had they
didn't have dedicated our developers
that didn't have dedicate python code so
they you buy I asked you to have them
flexible by Shane having a flexible to
use ah and python together they could
use different developers to get the job
done
I think that's that's an important Point
especially for whereas studio is going
like
going forward and unconscious of time
now because
um where we see the future is is through
sustainable remediation like this is
generally I tell you about the patient
Central you know it's basically giving
you what we did was a
research exercise where we compared the
data efficiency of doing the old
traditional technique between
independent spatial modeling versus one
spatial Central model and there was a
range of benefits including more
information using fewer observations
you can achieve the same level of
performance and if you turn that little
bit in his head you can say the spatial
temporal methods can achieve the same
level performance with fewer data points
right fewer data points means fewer
something like fewer fewer Journeys in
vehicles to do a fewer lab tests right
and and less impact an environment
and with that you know the and this is
the current theme
with our latest student
um Peter at the University of Glasgow so
we're trying to implement
cost-effective spatial temporal
approaches to optimize ground network
marketing monitor Network irrespective
of the design we know we can get more
the more data efficient it's actually
efficient using spatial temporal but if
you actually add the fact that we know
we're going to analyze it in spatial
tempting model and design it like that
we can even be more efficient means
effectively less sampling less Wells
and less impacts environment as well
um last closing Point
um I guess what haven't I done which I
would really like to do when you do
wrestler uh you know typical data format
is an Excel
and then that's because typically the
data sets are a warehouse in Excel but
more and more now
we're seeing you know Central databases
where it's managed in a lot better way
right and
the approach up to now has been
basically to
clearly these databases in
gws.format and then we just put them
into Excel spreadsheet but then that's
still the kind of two or three-step
process what I'd really like to do is
full integration right so you can log
into invest that and it actually gives
you a table and it automatically queries
that table from the site that you choose
so maybe one portal that you could
design and anyone if they share or any
organization but basically you know have
you know have their fingertips
and Analysis of all our groundwork
that's one of my to do in the future and
I think after you're doing that and how
much
and on that note Rachel
thank you so much Wayne it's amazing to
see how companies are able to to work
together too and and use this open
source work
I really love the the case studies that
you put on the the website I wanted to
share that in the chat with everybody in
in a minute here but it seems like
you've thought so much about the
marketing and communication of the app
as well
and like anticipating people's demands
and knowing that people should may want
to use this from Excel and using the
Excel add-in so I'm really curious how
do you gather all this user feedback and
kind of like know how to communicate
this out to everybody
yeah that's that's a good question
actually
um
um I would say we
although it might look like we do a lot
of marketing and communication it's it's
we probably didn't do as much as we
could have done right and I think
um
um but basically it's working hand in
hand with people
um understanding and Gathering their
feedback on the GitHub site there's a
list of suggestions for interviews and
the way I operate basically is you know
we get lots of different people asking
for lots of different functionality to
invest that but if lots of people are
asking for the same thing
right
um that's when it will go up the list of
priorities okay
that I I just realized is more on the
specific functionality of the US now but
in terms of um how do we Market it begin
with how do we promote it how would you
get feedback groundwater monitoring you
know there's a whole field environmental
engineering effectively uh in Shell as
teams who are fully integrated
presented in lots of different areas you
know would say we work hand in hand with
Claire that contaminated land action in
real environments that's becoming
European portal groundwater and we also
work with the American petroleum
professional bodies I would say is
probably the
the one one word I was there do that
question sorry that was a bit of a
long-winded uh answer that but but I
would say the thing that I think we're
lacking right and this is the resourcing
is Trading
you know it's quite intuitive to use
thankfully but I think you know the one
piece of feedback we're getting lately
is
there should be more training material
out there but in the process of putting
some videos together
awesome thank you
I see um Russ asked a great question
over on slido that I'll pull up in a
second but I just wanted to remind
everybody if you want to ask questions
you can ask them anonymously with the
link on the screen but you can also just
use LinkedIn or YouTube and it will pull
it over here for us
but let me show on the screen Russ said
hey Wayne very interesting solution
um what geospatial libraries are you
using here
you look on my GitHub
it will uh it will it should tell you
the dependency on the package
and you can see there look if I share
that if you do
there's the different packages that I'm
using there as well SM
Splunk so the ones
that we uh the spatial in nature
yeah
um we're not using any of the off the
show it can be fair there's there's very
little spatial temporal stuff out there
certainly nothing off the shelf
and those that are out there almost
insist on the data being regular in
nature because it's convenient for the
algebra but it's like we don't have
regular data so we've had to build our
own components
in there and all the police blank codes
is within the package source
I think this might have answered then
this question
um but are there additional geospatial
libraries you'd like to use instead but
would require too much rework
um
yeah I mean we are in the process of
building you know different
additional functionality input right I
don't think there's anything
there that we want to implement because
if it was we would have already
implemented it effectively right we're
having to build this stuff ourselves now
probably because it's not been done
before
the case in point you know what we've
implemented
um
leave leave one well-out analysis is the
latest thing so this is the ability to
basically just drop a well refit and
compare the results directly against one
like you know going forward they'll be
more sophisticated tools to do this you
know
um which will actually give you sampling
designs as to what
Wells you should certainly collect
different points here
we haven't found any much to my regret
we haven't found any of their packages
out there already
there we go so having to develop from
ourselves basically
if anybody knows of them feel free to
share them in the chat too
please do yeah that would be really good
another question
um that was over on slido anonymous
question was
I know you just share the GitHub but do
you have a reference for your work
generating the PowerPoint slides from
shiny
oh sorry I muted you
yeah yeah
I'm trying to think what we actually use
I think we use something like that right
but
um
uh if you have a look at the code it
will tell you how to do it
um if you search through the kit off the
top of my head I can't remember I think
it's using officer
repository search for PowerPoint and
you'll find it there as well there is a
very old-fashioned package called r2ppt
I Am the author of that package but it's
a bit outdated now and it's probably
going to get multiple from Crown fairly
soon
in fact if you look if you look at the
reproducible
research task View
of R you'll find here we go
this is a good one for telling you about
PowerPoints
perfect do you want to share that in the
oh you you're right on top of it I'll
just say share that in our private chat
here and I can copy that over
to the uh
one of the things that I have for
experimented with
is using our markdown as a report
right where instead of doing PowerPoints
like button you basically have an
animation in a Word document right
and what I found up to now it's very
easy to create sort of HTML reports and
PDFs a bit tougher with word
um but you know I think it needs to be
word because you know
the Consultants will need to always need
to amend a standard reform
so but that's still work in progress
I just saw a bunch of other
um
vital questions cover but I'm just going
to copy over so that I can show them on
the screen here
but one was
um is the for Excel manipulation is open
xlsx being used
sorry Wayne I was muting you because I
think it was echoing my voice but I
unrated you there
no it doesn't this is
we used to use a package called uh on
client but we found it
kind of not particularly well supported
um so I wrote a little bit of a hack to
be honestly right if you download and
you rest that ad in you will see that
all the code is there
on how to do it right so the way it
actually does it is it is it
dynamically builds like a text file
right on the Fly which which sort of
saves off your different variables and
all the rest of it and then it
sends that over together with the data
set as input to an R batch file
and that's kind of how it works as well
and that works fine because it's only
one-way traffic right in that you just
sending the data from Excel into our if
you had to do it the other way around as
well then the architecture what I'm
currently using before flatten this
place
I see
um some nice feedback in the the slido
hey Wayne nice presentation and shiny up
love how everything is reactive to input
widgets and how you've got rid of a
trigger button
and the uh the follow-up question there
was
how long did you take to build the
application and what were the key things
you knew needed to be in the app from
the start
yeah that's a good question right I mean
um
in terms of uh
yeah
it wasn't me that actually did the first
shiny version right we had a postdoc who
was doing it on a six-month basis but he
ported most of the functionality that
was there before
um and then I have added to it since
effectively right you know
D2 the number one was the spatial plot
right having that movie of the spatial
distribution and solid exchange it
through time is number one all right and
then everything effectively follows from
that that's the unique plot right that's
the plot that was really hard to do
in Excel for example which is typically
how some of the Consultants used to do
this in the past right you could do the
well-timed series plus you could do you
know different overlays and all rest of
it but the spatial distribution to your
time that's really
the the qua yeah the unique selling
point
hope that makes sense
and I guess I would say convenience as
well right having it all there in one
place you know in a reproducible
repeatable fashion right you know the
day it input's always the same and you
get lots of options on plotting the same
cannot be said of doing it in Excel
manually take you all day for people to
come up with the lattice of plots you
know you can do that in literally
seconds
yeah
thank you one other question is
did you have to make the case for using
open source
right this is this is a very good
question right I didn't you know what
you know it wasn't even my idea
all right
um it was the guys at the groundwater
they they they work in the space they
knew how it worked and they
they realized early on that open source
was the way to go for the for the
reasons I pointed out earlier you know
and what I'd say is you know shell is an
entity you know more and more you know
we're
we want to adopt use and also write open
source code as well as various people I
know
and it's also a really great motivator
right with our employees I think really
really like giving back
the sauce and we motivates to promote
loyalty in the staff this and I think
we'll do more of it going forward
and I I was just curious when and again
if anybody wants to ask other questions
just a reminder that you can if you just
join now you can ask them in YouTube you
can ask them in LinkedIn but you can
also use the um slido that I showed on
the screen right now to ask questions
anonymously too
um but thinking about like the upkeep of
the application and as you make
improvements to it out I was just
curious Wayne what does your team look
like and how many shiny developers do
you have and how many data scientists
yeah I mean well yeah what I'd say is
um there is I would say there's a
smallish team right you know so I have
Luke from the ground swollen groundwater
team he's the subject matter expert in
that field
and then I have the collaboration
University of Glasgow which tends to be
more the ldr in terms of support
maintenance it tends to be me right
um and again this comes back to being
open source I don't know whether
I mean I suppose I get you know four or
five emails a week or something like
that on average I'd say
um I don't know whether a lot of people
are using it and they have a small
number of issues or whether there's a
small number of people using it with a
large proportion of issues one of the
Throwbacks have been open source
um but yeah it is a worry really I mean
you know in terms of sustainability you
know if I fell underneath a bus got
forbid you know
I think there needs to be a better plan
B in place right too much of it is just
reliable on me for driving it
but that's one of the reasons why we're
doing it open and Transplant we welcome
people to come on board you know get
involved in these open source projects
you know so so it doesn't rely just
solely on one person so if anyone wants
to volunteer then you can gladly help
out by all means
thank you I see another question that
came over on slido from Ivan and is
thanks for sharing Wayne we're facing a
bottleneck with open xlsx going from R
to excel would have never thought of
calling R via VBA is the vva code in
GitHub too
vpa code is
Act is embedded to them Excel add-in
right
um if I just look at the code
but it's in I think it's in in the X
data and it's in that that file there
yeah so it's in that ad in there and all
the code is there visible for you to use
so I'll just put that in the chat again
together
okay perfect
thank you and I will copy that
over right now
so YouTube
and then over here to break in thank you
all for the great questions too I just
want to double check over to slido
because I see somebody just
asked about the link there
so just a reminder that
I put that link to ask questions into
the chat
um on YouTube and the chat on LinkedIn
but I'll show it once more on the the
screen here too
give people a second to to get their
final questions in there too
foreign
thank you so much for sharing the GitHub
links as well it's really helpful to be
able to share these code examples with
everyone too
I was curious when I know you mentioned
the LinkedIn group for gws. but if
people are interested in in working on
this with you what's the best place to
get in touch with you
but just dropped me an email
oh your audio just went out for a little
bit if you want to get a little closer
bye
alternatively you know have a look at
the
GitHub page and you know have a look at
the issues
suggest some enhancements honestly I
mean what I'd say about it it's a very
specific tools like the specifically
right so
it you know really apply but that's his
kind of strength really is that it's
very specific tool for a specific area
so really you can look at the people
that work in the geology space
you have a bit of the main noise to come
in and be able to help on that side as
well but
everyone is welcome to help believe me
I see one other question that somebody
just put into the YouTube chat
um and they said I'm curious to know how
you manage any confounding variables
with the data provided in the open
source you presented
let's see you can try and copy this over
um sorry they asked to be anonymous so I
don't want to just like show it up on
the screen but I can I can reread it it
said I'm curious to know how they manage
any confounding variables with the data
provided
in the open source you presented or or
biased data
it's a good question right I would say
typically we don't have anything
yes
uh I'm going to explain why in a minute
um
uh in the time series plots right it's
not like we're doing a regression we've
won against the other it's always
Against Time right so it's always
against an index
when it comes to fitting the spatial
plot right it's using splines all right
it sort of uses a three-dimensional
spline basis
um and obviously
these variables by Design I'm not going
to confound another the danger there is
overfitting like more than confounding
parameters and this is where peace plan
comes into its own is that it penalizes
the step changes from these parameters
estimated from the spline and that's
what controls the degree of complexity
imbalances between Under and Over
fitting effectively yeah so
confounding variables isn't really an
issue for that reason because we're
spine by Design they're not confounded
overfitting is but it's controlled
through this penalized drawing framework
like
awesome I think we we got to everybody's
questions over here on on slido and
YouTube and Linkedin thank you all for
for the great questions
um I did just want to
let everybody know that while you're all
here if you are interested in joining
future events we'd love to see you at
those
um you can view upcoming meetups which
happen every Tuesday at the same time at
this calendar here and we also have a
data science hangout every Thursday at
noon eastern time as well where you can
hear from different data science leaders
in the space in a very informal setting
in Afghani in all questions to them
but next week I am very excited to also
have a presentation on intro to using
git and GitHub in our studio and so that
will be next Tuesday
but just want to say thank you so much
Wayne it's amazing to see how
see your team's use case and and hear
about your experience it's really
awesome to hear how you're working
together with environmental agencies and
other companies as well through this too
thank you so much for sharing with us
have a great rest of the day everybody
thank you bye
thanks Wayne